MITCHELL FOLEY: Hello.
My name is Mitchell Foley.
I am a software engineer on the
Google Visualization API.
All right.
So, how many people are actually
familiar with the
Google Visualization API?
All right.
Actually a pretty good number.
That's much more than
I expected.
For those of you who haven't
heard of it before, well, I'll
give you a good introduction
to what it is and why you
might want to use
it right now.
So, what you can do with it,
it's actually a JavaScript API
that is available for free
for the public to use.
It's not only used by customers
outside of Google.
You might want to use it on
your personal website.
But it's used by internal
clients as well.
Like Google Docs, AdWords,
AdSense, YouTube Analytics; we
get a lot of customers
inside Google.
And what we want to do is we
want to take your data, and we
want to transform it into a
beautiful visualization that
you can use to tell
your story.
To convey a message
to your users.
And you can do that a couple
of different ways.
So we'll show you first,
one of our biggest
clients, Google Docs.
And what we have here is just
a spreadsheet with a little
bit of data.
How much pizza I had last
night for dinner.
Probably had a little
too much.
But we just took our-- the
type of pizza, and
the number of slices.
Put them in a couple of cells,
highlighted it, and then made
a chart out of it.
Very, very simple stuff.
But we can also do this just
on a regular HTML page.
So here's just a very,
very basic HTML page.
What we're doing here
is we're including
a very simple script.
This is the Google's
JS API loader.
You can use it to load a number
of different libraries,
the visualization library
being one of them.
And we also have a placeholder
div here for our chart.
We're going to write a script
that you'll see in the next
page where we actually insert
the chart into this div.
OK.
So it looks like a big slide
full of code here, but it's
actually not too complicated.
We're not doing anything really
complicated here.
The first thing we're doing is
with that loader script that
we saw on the previous slide,
we're actually going to tell
it what we want to load.
And we want to load, in this
case, the core chart package.
We have a number of different
packages.
In this case, we just want that
simple bar chart that you
saw earlier.
So that's one of our
core charts.
And we're going to say, OK,
please load this core chart
package for us.
And when you're finished
loading, call this function.
This is just JavaScript.
It just runs right
in the browser.
And so it calls our callback
drawStuff.
Now once we know that we have
all of the classes, and
objects, and everything that we
need to draw the chart, we
can start to do that.
So the first thing we need
to do here is we need
to set up our data.
So we need to get our data
into a data table.
And the data table is the basic
construct that we use to
pass our data around, to format
it, to write extra
information about
it if necessary.
In this case, we're just doing a
very simple data table where
we're saying the topping and
the number of slices.
So we add our two columns, we
add our slices and the amount
we ate, then we need to set
some chart options.
Now these chart options,
there's a lot
of different options.
Most of them you can apply to
actually any visualization
that you want.
This one we're just going to
set a title, and then the
width and the height of what
the chart area is.
And finally, we'll construct
the chart object and
actually draw it.
And this is what we get.
It looks exactly the same as
it did in the other slide.
One other good thing to note is
that this is actually fully
interactive.
And you can see my mouse there.
Good.
And so when the user hovers
over, they can actually see
more details about each
of the data points.
So we're just highlighting
different things, and it's
giving us tool tips that provide
extra information
about our data.
So why would you want
to do this?
Why would you want to use charts
instead of just data
tables or HTML tables like
this to tell the
story of your data?
And it's really that.
It's the storytelling.
Being able to visually see
something is going to be much
more effective than having,
you know, Hamilton-Norwood
stage with a bunch of numbers.
I'm guessing not a lot of
people in here are even
familiar with the
Hamilton-Norwood stage.
I certainly wasn't before
I wrote this.
And so we can take this.
We can put it into
a data table.
And we can easily make a bunch
of different charts.
And these are some
very basic ones.
None of these really tell
the right story.
They don't really tell
you, what am I
trying to convey here?
We get a bunch of names,
but we don't--
what's going on?
So we can actually see, if we
tell the story correctly, what
we get is we get a story of how
the Google Visualization
Development Team is follically
challenged.
Not a lot of hair on the team.
We see Sergey, Dan, and
Jeremy, they're really
bringing in all the
hair to the team.
We're trying to get them
haircuts, but we'll see.
And so this is what I want to do
is, over the next half hour
or so, I want to tell a story.
And I want to tell a story using
all of the new features
that we've been working on for
the past year, to help you
tell stories with your data.
And again, this is fully
interactive.
So the story I'm gonna
tell you is about me.
And it's about me becoming
an adult.
There's been a lot of events
in my life recently where I
feel much more grown up
than I did really a
couple months ago.
I've talked to a lot of people
about becoming an adult.
Nobody really knows
what that means.
Are there any adults here?
I'm not seeing very
many hands at all.
So, I'm guessing you've
all experienced the
same things I have.
The first thing is
the timeline.
This is a brand new
visualization that we've been
working on.
And the ability to show
different points in history
and really tell the story.
So right here, you can see, I
got engaged in March of 2012.
Thank you.
Google I/O, giving this talk.
This is a pretty big grown
up moment for me.
There's a lot of people here.
A lot of people are going to
be watching this on YouTube
later on, hopefully.
So giving the I/O talk, that's
a reasonable amount of
responsibility.
Condo.
So I'm in the process of closing
on a condo right now.
I'm from Boston.
Real estate isn't quite as crazy
as it is here, but it's
still reasonably insane.
And married.
I mentioned I got engaged, we
have a wedding date set for
early September of this year.
So a lot of planning all
going on at once.
A lot of new responsibilities.
A lot of uncharted
territories.
And this timeline really helps
to show you how we have, kind
of, more things all scrunched
together at the end there then
I would have liked to deal with
at once, but there it is.
All right, so let's go over
the code for this.
If my clicker works.
All right.
So first thing is, you notice on
the previous visualizations
where I just had the basic bar
charts, is that here, we're
loading a new type
of visualization.
This isn't one of
our core charts.
So you can actually load this
independently from the core
chart package.
So we're loading the timeline
package instead here.
The basic steps are
still the same.
We're creating our data table.
We're using a little bit of
a different method here.
We're just converting a
JavaScript array directly into
a data table.
So once we have our data
table, and we have our
options, now we're just going
to construct our chart.
And the chart, instead of doing
column chart like we
were previously, we're
just doing timeline.
And the Google Visualization
API does all of
the work for you.
They figure out, OK, what are
the four best colors that will
contrast with each other nicely,
that's going to really
make this visualization pop?
What's going to stand
out the most?
How far apart should
all of the labels
be on the tick axis?
So you can see it shows a
quarterly interval here.
And it said, this is what's
really going to tell the story
the best; the most effectively
for you.
So all you have to do is provide
it your data, and it
will say, OK, I'll do all
the work for you.
But we can actually make this
a bit more complicated.
There's more than just
those four events.
I mean obviously, there's
a lot of work leading
up to each of those.
So you can see here, I went
ring shopping for about a
month and a half.
And engaged--
engaged isn't just a
point in time, it's
really a long term thing.
Well, in my case it's
a long term thing.
I'm going to be engaged about
a year and a half before
everything's said and done.
Buying the condo.
That is not a one
moment in time.
That is a long, long process.
Long process.
So we had to do condo
shopping.
And writing this I/O
presentation even
took a bunch of time.
So here you can see, instead of
just the one category here,
that just says grown up stuff,
now I have three separate
categories.
I have a relationship, a condo,
and the I/O category.
So you can further divide
your data to even more
clearly tell the story.
Now in order to do that, the
only difference here is I'm
providing, instead of
just one category--
so you can see where it
says relationship, and
condo, and I/O here--
it used to just say
grown up stuff.
We can see that back here.
See, it just says
grown up stuff.
So now I'm giving three
different categories.
And it's figuring out, OK, now
that I have these three
different categories, I
should put them all
onto different lines.
I'm also setting ranges now.
So instead of points in history,
like with the I/O
being today--
or two days ago, I guess
I have that set for--
we're setting a start date and
an end date, rather than just
a point in history.
But other than that,
everything's
pretty much the same.
We're not adding a ton of new
complexity to get this new
functionality.
And even still, we can actually
stack events on top
of each other within
a category.
So if you want to show
concurrency, or a schedule,
for example, you can do that.
So with the condo shopping, I've
had to talk to realtors,
banks, and lawyers.
Which are a fun group of
people to talk to.
Living together with
my fiancee.
So you can see when that
happened in perspective to
being engaged and
getting married.
Wedding planning, you
can see happened the
second we got engaged.
Probably a little bit earlier
for my fiancee.
That's right.
And these again, are completely
interactive.
So you'll be able to see the
exact date ranges, and all of
the information that
you want, through
the interaction events.
So you can just get a nice big
summary, and then you can
actually have your users drill
deeper into the data as
they're interacting with
the visualization.
So you can tell your story.
Again, just very, very basic.
We're just going to add some new
rows into our data table.
Nothing different about this
data, it just happens to
coincide at the same time
as other events.
So the visualization will just
stack the bars nicely on top
of each other.
That's a lot of stuff.
All right.
So that's the timeline
visualization.
Which is not available quite
yet, but it will be available
in about a week or so
in our version 1.1.
And I'll give you the links
for everything at the end.
Blood pressure.
So with all of these events
happening in my life, all at
the same time, it can get
a little stressful.
Get a little bit stressful.
And so, here we're seeing my
blood pressure over a course
of about six months, I'd say.
Taken once every 15 days.
It's all over the place.
It's up and down.
It's everywhere.
And actually, this isn't just
stressful for me, but it's
also stressful for my mother.
She's very concerned.
She still thinks of me as a
six-year-old that needs
everything taken care of.
I love you Mom, but relax.
So this is a scatter chart.
Let's drill into how we make
this scatter chart.
Now there's a lot more data on
this visualization then with
the previous visualizations.
So we're going to move all of
our data table setup to
another function, just so I
can fit it on two slides.
And all it is, is a date,
and then two values.
It's systolic, if you're really
concerned about what
these blood pressure
numbers mean.
And we're just building
our data table.
And here, the only different
thing is, where we're saying,
draw a scatter chart.
Now we could have had a
line chart to plot the
lines, if we wanted.
But other than that, everything
is very simple.
And then the visualization
library is taking care of
everything for us.
Now, when you make something
like a scatter chart, what
you're really trying to do is
your saying, here are my data
points, but there's gotta to be
a pattern here somewhere.
We want to see the trends.
And so to help you make these
trends, what we did was we add
in automatic trend
line calculation.
So that's just saying, given
this set of data, I want a
linear trend line.
And you can actually
go over here.
So you can see, on March 1, my
blood pressure was at 140.
My mother's was at 130.
So I was actually a little more
stressed out that day
than she was.
And you can also see along the
different trend lines, what
both the formula for the trend
line is, and what the
calculated value should be,
what is the expected value
based on that trend line.
You can go on, you can compare
all of these numbers.
And it's really a nice
interactive experience for
telling your story.
And you can see here, I am
getting more stressed out as
time goes on, but my mother is
about to explode any minute
now, really.
So let's take a look at
how we add in these
automatic trend lines.
Again, we're doing the data
table set up on the previous
slide, with the get blood
pressure data table function.
All we're doing here to get
the trend lines is we're
saying, in our options, add
a couple of trend lines to
series zero and series one.
You'll notice it says
type "linear".
We can also do exponential
if we feel that's more
appropriate for our data.
But it's very, very simple, and
we want to expose this to
everybody, so you can better
see these patterns in your
data, so you can better
tell your story.
And one more look
at this table.
All right.
Condo shopping, was
another big part.
If anybody's ever--
even if you've just gone
looking for apartments,
there's a lot of data.
You have square footage, versus
time to work, versus
how much is it going
to cost you.
All kinds of different
variables.
One of the ways you can actually
display a lot of
these variables all at once
is with a bubble chart.
So this is something that
already exists today.
And we have this bubble chart.
So you can see, on the y-axis,
we have the size of unit.
We have how much the unit
costs on the x-axis.
The size of the bubble
corresponds to
how far it is from--
how much of a commute
it will be to work.
And the color of the bubble is
the number of fireplaces.
I really want a fireplace
in my place.
So I figured I'd put
that up there too.
And you can hover over these
and see exactly the exact
details of all of these.
You can say, OK, list price is
$319,900 for this place.
And it's going to take me 41
minutes to get to work.
So this was a really useful way
for my fiancee and I to
see all of these different
listings all at once.
So let's see how exactly
I draw that.
The first thing I'm doing here
is you're going to notice a
couple of different options
that are more for just the
bubble chart.
And so you have--
I'm manually setting the labels
for these, as well as
setting a style on the bubble.
I thought the text on the bubble
was a little too big,
so I made it a little smaller.
And this is just one of the many
things you can customize.
I'm drawing a bubble chart this
time, instead of a line
chart or a scatter chart
or a timeline.
So I just call a bubble
chart instead.
You might also know this,
are people in here
familiar with jQuery?
Just, you've heard of it?
Yes.
Everybody's heard of jQuery.
All right.
Awesome.
jQuery is a library that
provides a number of
convenience methods, is one of
the many things it does.
And here, what it's doing is
it's actually making an XML
request for a blob
of JSON, that
actually has all the data.
And I'll show you what
that data looks like.
So this is just a JSON file
that I had generated.
It has the addresses, the
prices, it rips all these from
various real estate
listing websites.
You'll notice that the end of
each row here is a URL.
And I'm not really doing
anything with this URL.
On my chart here, once I decide,
OK, 358 Lexington
Street here is worth
looking at.
So how do I say, OK, I want
to go look at this?
How do I know?
So we actually added this
functionality, actions.
And so with the actions API, you
can actually go in and add
more interactive elements
to your tool tips.
In this case it would be really
useful if I could just
click on this, and then view
this on the listing website.
So if I click on that--
I'm not connected
to the internet.
All right.
That's OK.
It comes up with a beautiful
picture of the house, and
maybe a map, and how much it
costs, and the real estate
agent I would need to
get in touch with.
And this is something that's
really made it much easier for
us to find a place to live.
And this was not, I mean this
is not a lot of code.
And it's much, much nicer than
most of the tools out there
that I've found.
So, to add the action.
How do we do this?
This is a little bit different
than we've seen
in our other features.
What we're doing here is, after
we've constructed the
chart object, our bubble chart,
we're going to set an
action on it.
And the majority of stuff, the
juicy bits of this, is really
this action function here.
The action function says, when
I click on that little label
inside the tool tip, what
do we do with it?
And so all I do is I want
to get the selection.
I already have the URL that's
in the data table.
So I want to say, OK, based on
my selection, I want to get
the cell with the URL
from the row.
So we're going to get
the selection.
And then we're going to get the
value at the fifth column.
And then we're going
to open the URL.
And that's all there is to it.
I mean, it's just JavaScript,
so you can do anything you
want within that function.
And really, this was like an
incredibly useful tool when
searching for real estate.
It really helps to visualize
where everything is, how far
away everything is, rather than
just looking at pictures
of the inside.
You can really see a
lot of data all the
once with the bubble.
So that was a very
good experience.
Hopefully the closing
will go well.
The wedding.
The wedding there's a lot--
I have a very big family.
I have a big international
family.
They're coming from all
over the place.
And it's tough to visualize
stuff like this.
So we actually do offer
a geochart.
And the geochart's going to
show us where all of these
wedding guests are
coming from.
And we can see, OK, I've got a
lot of people from Greenland,
it looks like, and some Irish
relatives, and a couple of
people from the Ukraine, and
maybe one guy from Spain.
And you can map out all
the data you want.
And these will be geocoded
for you.
So let's take a look at how
we're constructing this data.
So I'm not actually providing
anything complicated for my
data table.
I'm providing just the
name of the country.
Common names here going to be
cached by the library, so you
won't need to make a network
request to figure out, OK,
what is Ireland?
Where is that on my map?
It'll actually just know that.
More complex names, if you want
to provide longitude and
latitude, it'll make a geocoding
request to the
Google Maps API.
And this is all done
automatically for you.
So here we're just saying the
region that the guests are
coming from, and then
the number of guests
coming from that area.
Here we need to load a different
package than we've
loaded before.
We're going to load the
geochart package.
And then we're going to
construct the geochart object.
So very, very simple to
create a geochart.
But if you look, this is
actually a Mercator
projection.
And a Mercator projection
is basically how
you're going to--
a map projection first of all,
is how you're going to take
the globe, and translate
it to a flat surface?
And here is the Mercator
projection.
And this Mercator projection
is very common.
I'm sure you've all seen
a map of the world
that looks like this.
And it was really designed
for marine navigation.
And that's pretty much it.
And that's pretty much
all it's useful for.
And if you look at Greenland,
it's giant.
It's bigger than Africa.
Mercator, you're going to take
something, and you're going to
stretch it out such that if you
were to go directly side
to side here, so you go from
Maine, you would end up
somewhere in France.
Exactly east.
But this isn't really too useful
for seeing things.
When I was a little kid, and
I knew my relatives from
Greenland, I thought they
must be super powerful.
Because Greenland must
be super powerful,
because it's giant.
But Mercator really isn't
appropriate here.
So we've added the ability
to have different map
projections.
So you can decide what is the
best way to show this data.
And this is a Kavrayskiy VII.
And this map projection is
going to give you minimal
distortion.
So here you can see, wow,
Greenland is a much more
reasonable size.
Australia is a much more
Everything looks
in proportion.
And this projection is really
designed so that each of the
individual regions are
minimally distorted.
So to change my visualization
to have a different
projection, all I'm doing here
is adding another option.
And this option is just going
to say, OK, I want not the
default projection.
I want to specify
the Kavrayskiy
VII projection instead.
So we can go back, and
we can see a much
nicer view of the world.
I also have a lot of people
visiting from within the
United States.
You can see the view of the
United States here.
Again, it's a little
stretched out.
This is the Mercator
projection again.
This isn't really what the
United States looks like.
Everything's kind of distorted,
the further you
venture away from the equator.
But in order to construct this,
we're just passing the
state codes.
And most of these are
cached again.
So we're creating our data table
with all of the states
and the number of visitors.
In order to zoom in on a
specific region, we're just
going to provide that
in the options.
So in this case, we want
to view the US region.
And we have our Mercator
projection
of the United States.
But a more appropriate
projection for the United
States is the Albers
projection.
And this is actually what I'm
used to seeing when I see a
map of the United
States, is this.
So in order to specify this
projection, we're going to,
again, give it the projection
option.
But this one's a little
different.
This one you're able to
specify parallels.
And some projections
require you to
specify these parallels.
Where is the projection
essentially centered around?
So this might be 29 and 1/2, 45
and 1/2, that's appropriate
for the United States.
But it might not be appropriate
for the European
Union, for example.
So these are good ones.
It will choose these by
default, if you want.
But these are ones I wanted
to hand pick.
So again, we can see the
Albers, the equal area.
And we can actually go back
and compare a little.
So if you look at Minnesota
and Florida, and how they
really shift between the two.
And even that the distance,
you can see Maine and
Washington kind of
coming together.
It really demonstrates the
amount of distortion that each
of the projections
is making up for.
All right.
Get you guys out of here
and get you to lunch.
So our new features.
We had the new visualization in
the timeline visualization.
We added the ability to
add in trend lines.
We have actions, new
interactions
for our tool tips.
And map projections, for more
appropriately displaying geocharts.
And all of this is for free,
and you see this at
developers.google.com/chart.
And it's a simple
JavaScript API.
And that's about all I had.
[AUDIENCE CLAPS]
MITCHELL FOLEY: Thank you.
If anyone has any questions, I'm
happy to take questions.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick one.
Ken Anderson from University
of Colorado.
I've been really excited to
learn more about Dart while
I've been here.
And I'm wondering what is the
timeline, or are there plans
in place to integrate services
like these in to Dart?
Because right now, I don't know
how easy it is to call
existing JavaScript libraries
straight from Dart.
MITCHELL FOLEY: So, I know of
no way currently, with Dart.
We haven't discussed this
with our team at all.
I will say that we have worked
a lot with GWT, Google Web
Toolkit, so we do have GWT
wrappers for all of these.
But as far as Dart, if you can
call JavaScript code from
Dart, then you'll be able
to call this from Dart.
But there are no specific
Dart wrappers.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Timothy Wall
with CloudLock.
I'm looking forward to seeing
the timeline come out.
I've currently got a
visualization based on Google
App Engine costs over time.
MITCHELL FOLEY: OK.
AUDIENCE: So we can see the
usage and spiking of costs.
And we also have that mapped
in with another data source
that shows sort of what's
going in the
application at the time.
So we end up having a
lot of events there.
And the default formatting for
injecting, I guess they're
called annotations, into the
graph is rather limited.
Do you have any plans, or is
there anything upcoming to
allow more customization of the
annotations that are put
on a given visualization?
MITCHELL FOLEY: We're absolutely
looking into adding
more customizations
all the time.
My recommendation would
be to complain on the
public mailing list.
We really do listen to
everything on all of the
mailing lists that we receive.
We have had some complaints
from--
well, had some feature
requests, to add more
annotations.
I don't think I can talk about
specific schedules or promise
anything right now.
AUDIENCE: I noticed with the
action, it looked like the
specific data around that
had been formatted in
a particular way.
I don't know if that was
customized or if that's the
default presentation.
MITCHELL FOLEY: That was
actually the default
customization.
I was running that exact code
to make that presentation.
I think I might have changed the
size a little bit for the
presentation.
But other than that, that
was the default.
There is some customization.
And we're always looking to
improve the customizability of
our product.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: So I know you said the
colors are chosen kind of
based on what pops the most.
Is there any way to override
that for branding purposes for
certain companies who
want to use their
colors in their logo?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Absolutely.
It's not always appropriate
to use the default colors.
For example, sometimes red,
you'll want to be indicating a
high number, like with
temperature.
But sometimes you want
it to be a low
number, like with money.
So yes, there are ways.
And read all about them on
developers.google.com/charts.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MITCHELL FOLEY: No problem.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is there any intention to make
this available within Android
apps, rather than
just on the web?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Mobile is
a very important part of
Google's strategy as a whole.
Right now, these charts
will output to SVG.
We are actively working
to make them better.
Adding in support for touch
events, for example.
But they will render just
fine right now on
a native web browser.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You showed a number
of the, for example, the
timeline charts.
Is there a way to have two of
the charts kind of stacked one
above each other?
So using your example again,
showing not just your blood
pressure chart, but showing that
over the timeline chart,
and being able to have a
vertical line move between
them to show where you are
looking at any given point?
MITCHELL FOLEY: So we do have
the ability for you to add an
arbitrary number of charts
onto a page.
As far as adding a line right
down the middle, we don't have
support for that yet.
But we do have the ability to
build dashboards, where you
can transform your data,
for all of your
charts, all at once.
So you can have the data
change the range.
So you can go through
time like that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MITCHELL FOLEY: But as far as
the line, that specific way of
showing that story,
we don't yet.
AUDIENCE: So, putting multiple
charts on a page at the time,
that's just a matter
of putting in two
divs and having them--
MITCHELL FOLEY: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: More or less aligned
with each other.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MITCHELL FOLEY: No problem.
AUDIENCE: I'm excited about the
timeline charts as well.
I was wondering if there's
a way to specify your
own metric for time?
Like if you wanted to do
geologic epochs or something
like that, and still
use those tools.
MITCHELL FOLEY: So in addition
to passing in dates, you can
just pass in numbers.
It will try to convert those
to dates, and it does a
reasonably good job.
I guess beyond that,
there's not a lot.
It will display no matter what
numbers you put in there.
So there's that.
I would recommend, once it's
released, play around with it,
and see if it fits your needs.
And if it doesn't,
let us know.
Really let us know.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MITCHELL FOLEY: We're always
looking for more feedback.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I think Google Visualization
API is a static chart by
static data, from my
understanding.
So do you have a plan to develop
real-time chat by
updating Ajax or WebSockets,
something like that?
MITCHELL FOLEY: I'm sorry.
Could you repeat the question?
AUDIENCE: So do you
have a plan to
develop a real-time chart?
I think Google chart is
static chart, I think.
Do you have plans of updating
by the Ajax or WebSockets,
visualize in real time?
MITCHELL FOLEY: We don't provide
that, however you can
just update the chart.
So if you write a--
if you have it at
a set interval
on a page, for example.
And you're saying,
redraw the chart.
So you can see, let me
go back to some code.
AUDIENCE: You have
transformations on
charts, don't you?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Absolutely.
So right here, where we're
going chart.draw--
AUDIENCE: Ahh.
MITCHELL FOLEY: --you can save
that chart object and just
call chart.draw again,
with different data
and different options.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MITCHELL FOLEY: And we actually
do have animation
transitions between
those two states.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: In fact, a similar
question here.
The use case is like a livestock
price scenario where
there's data that streams--
comes in every minute or two,
and instead of reloading all
the JSON data table, is there
a way to just feed the delta
that we have for the last
minute into the chart?
MITCHELL FOLEY: You
could certainly
add onto a data table--
AUDIENCE: OK.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Once
you've finished
constructing the data table.
AUDIENCE: And then I
will do draw again?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Yes.
So you can say, OK, add this
data, remove this data, and
then redraw.
Or just add data, or
just remove data.
Whatever you'd like to do.
AUDIENCE: If I just add data,
it won't draw automatically?
I have to programmatically
call the draw?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Correct.
You just have to have that
one extra call where it's
chart.draw.
AUDIENCE: I see, thank you.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if you have any
options to download the
data table on the client?
MITCHELL FOLEY: You
can convert data
tables to a JSON string.
And so you can expose that
functionality to your users.
And then you can actually
provide just a JSON blob to
the data table to reconstruct
it in a different context.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was looking at the scatter
graph, and I was wondering if
there is an option to
provide threshold.
For example, you had blood
pressure, and I want to look
at blood pressure beyond
certain numbers.
Say 140, red.
And below a certain number, bad,
it's low blood pressure.
So can you visualize that in
the scatter graph or some
other form of graph?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Yes.
So I mentioned, in addition to
providing just the raw data
table, you can also
set attributes.
And one of the things
you can set is--
my goodness, I forget the
term that we use off
the top of my head.
But you can--
ah, roles.
You can assign roles.
And so you can assign a scope
role to a piece of data and
say, this is out of scope
or this is in scope.
And it will color that
data appropriately.
So if you want to only highlight
the ones that are
within the range, you can
assign a scope role
to do that for you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Are these controlled
ADA compliant?
MITCHELL FOLEY: I'm sorry,
say that one more time.
AUDIENCE: The timeline and
all this visualization
controllers, are they
ADA compliant?
ADA compliant, section 503.
The accessibility?
MITCHELL FOLEY: No.
Not yet.
We are working on-- there's
actually some really exciting
things that we're working
on right now.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MITCHELL FOLEY: They are not
finished, but we are thinking
about accessibility, and we'll
hopefully have a better answer
for you shortly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
When I look at all the
[INAUDIBLE], like just give
"Ireland" and map Ireland
automatically, it looks really
like Fusion Table.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Mm hmm.
AUDIENCE: Functionality.
What's the plan in the future
between Fusion Table and
releasing all of
those features?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Could you say
that one more time please?
AUDIENCE: What's a roadmap
behind it having all those
features for [INAUDIBLE]
developers to
integrate in the website?
And right now going through
Fusion Table, to have the same
results and same story at
the end of the day?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Are you asking
about Fusion Tables?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MITCHELL FOLEY: I honestly
don't know too much about
Fusion Tables.
Does anybody have any idea?
AUDIENCE: It's a
Google product.
It comes from Google, too.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Believe it or
not, they don't consult me on
everything.
I have my charts and graphs
and stuff, but I actually
don't know too much about Fusion
Tables, I'm very sorry.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So, if I want to set
the scale on the chart on the
side, do I have other ways to
do besides just a static
linear chart that encompasses
all the data?
Can I have data that's off the
chart and just have that sort
of disconnected and appear
above it, and say this is
constrained to between
80 and 120, or
whatever the values are?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And also, can you
do a non-linear scale?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can I do a
logarithmic scale, for example?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Yes.
Both of those, absolutely.
You can set the axis
scale yourself.
You can set the start and
end points for anything.
You can also set custom
logarithmic scales for
everything.
Including the points at which
you want to show on the axis.
All of that's documented
on the site.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I am really excited
to hear about
1.1 coming out soon.
I was wondering if there were
any other new charts in 1.1,
or if there were any other new
releases with new charts in it
in the upcoming roadmap?
MITCHELL FOLEY: So right
now, the only brand new
visualization is the timeline.
We do want to eventually
provide even more
visualizations.
As far as 1.0 versus 1.1,
1.0 is always the
current stable version.
1.1 is always the
beta version.
So eventually we'll merge
1.1 to be 1.0.
It's our numbering scheme.
I don't know what to tell
you about that.
AUDIENCE: So when's the
next 1.1 coming?
MITCHELL FOLEY: In
about a week.
In about a week, you'll be able
to play around, you'll
have timelines on 1.1, and be
able to play around with that.
Hopefully another month after
we get the testing and any
bugs fixed, we'll get that out
in maybe a month or so after.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So are there any more new charts
coming in the next six
to 12 months?
MITCHELL FOLEY: Yes.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MITCHELL FOLEY: Thank you.
Any more questions?
OK, well, if there's not, I'm
happy to stick around for a
couple minutes.
Thank you for coming, and
enjoy your lunch.